I'm thrilled to see this man not only
because I thoroughly enjoy his work and
certainly when he stops by on this show
but because his new Netflix comedy
special paper tiger when it was released
on Tuesday got him trending on Twitter I
was genuinely concerned for his
well-being so it's good to see you bill
cancelled well no well canceled from
life you know you see people trend on
Twitter and it's all of a sudden like
certainly when they're of a certain age
you're like oh no so that's why one I
want Twitter when it's usually something
bit did they die right did something bad
happen right I'm speaking of that Kevin
Hart's out of the hospital which makes
me feel really oh god is that that
happen today did I think yesterday yeah
I saw that trend whether it's true now I
don't know oh yeah he's back which is
great okay but you're back and you're
here yeah see yes I'm feeling good
everybody good you're good yeah no
mononucleosis no nothing I know I did
porchetta fancy all you can say is jet
fans having suffered for a long time as
a sports fan it just makes it all the
better when you finally win it and when
you're talking about the Browns being
cursed just they have one for NFL titles
and for some reason the NFL acts like
prior to the merger nothing happened
right
which so what Jim Brown isn't a champion
I go to he's not on that he can't talk
to a Super Bowl champion eyeball the
eyeball it makes no sense me and every
other splake logo NHL they count titles
all the way back to one like the Stanley
Cup was like this big this is like a
beer mug and they played on like a pond
you know the Montreal Maroons way it was
let's all take a trip on the Titanic all
of those and then for some reason like
it's not like the NHL didn't merge a
couple of times I think they took what
was it the the WHL took a couple teams
there or the IHL it took a couple teams
from there there's the original six and
then in now there's you know I call this
surviving six because there was more
than six in the depression wiped out all
those montreal maroon teams and all
those so those were the six teams that
survived and then they continued on and
on and on and on doing what they were
doing and then what was weird this is
all that's what I love about the NHL is
that you always do everything so weird
so then in 67 the expansion they added
six teams so if you already have six
established teams and you add six yes
when you put three
and three during the East Coast three in
the West Coast they didn't they kept one
conference of all original six and then
they had one conference of all the new
people so when that's why when the
Bruins like went to the finals they had
already played the Stanley they already
played for the championship because
they're playing the Blues which were an
expansion team yeah and we beat him I
think yeah four games well before the
NFL did some realignment to Atlanta was
in the NFC West
there was no Geographic sensibility
whatsoever yeah like the Red Wings
always got screwed with that was always
considered like a nice less team right
yeah their Detroit Red Wings are always
west you know just that was when
Michigan you know the fight song says
champions of the West that was you know
Michigan was around before the Louisiana
Purchase
that's what I always that why it's yeah
yeah man you during that army so I was
that much I was at my son's soccer game
okay and my phone was running out of
batteries based on how many times I was
getting all of these updates I was
supposed to be a cupcake game you think
I mean it was downright frightening but
Army's one of those teams to that you
just gotta you know have you Oklahoma
almost lost to him last year where were
you now what again what's your
connection family have a couple uh I
have some family on both sides okay they
have lived out there or still live out
there and so yeah I was I was brought up
to like Michigan Ohio State but it was
great because when I did it I was when
Woody Hayes when I first started
watching Woody Hayes was still at Ohio
State and both and yeah Bo Schembechler
yeah the 10-year war the woody yeah
10-year war yes I got to watch that
right up until when Woody Hayes you can
even punch him that hard but when he was
that guy for intercepting the ball I
just saw it like jeez the passion that
this guy has I also remember to seeing a
documentary on the the michigan ohio
state rivalry yes after you know they
were talking about how the Red Sox and
Yankees was like the biggest thing you
know like ten years ago before we enter
the curse or whatever
fifteen years ago and once I watch that
documentary I was like oh this is
nothing compared to what these people
went through of course as far as like
the level of just hatred
so where were you for the Michigan Army
game I was in Vegas I was doing a show
out there and I'd hung around an extra
day to go see Elton John cuz he's on the
farewell tour which is amazing show is
it really three hours show no opener
opens with the hit plays nothing but
hits for three hours it's unbelievable
that goes by like that no kidding yeah
you got to see him too and what that guy
is like put himself through as a
performer one point he got up and walked
across from the piano he looked like a
retired NFL running back and they're
showing in the videos the stuff I used
to do you'd be like doing handstands in
those high heels Bootsy war and stuff
just crushing his hips and his knees
that's why he's walking around as a
fellow performer I was watching like
this guy for 50 years as understood that
people paid to get his sitter
right took a night off you know spending
their hard-earned money and gave you a
show
so and he was like yeah he was like a
great pitcher right now you know maybe
didn't still have like the fastball but
he knew how to still crafty crafty he's
crafty he was great he's crowd that came
off right I eat it anyway I'd say that's
good but you were in Vegas so that's
where you were for this sorry did you
watch the game in a sports book or
something yeah I came down there and I
saw these happy Buckeye fans I was like
oh no what's happening like these happy
Buckeye fans watching Michigan versus
what do you know I hate to say it they
totally dominated Michigan this entire
century and the joy they still get it's
unreal like at some point you got to
kind of be like you know I mean even I
don't hate the Yankees as much as I used
to because it's it's it's kind of over
like what so well as far as the you know
curse of the babe 1988 chant last year's
number at me I mean I know we're never
gonna catch catch 27 championship right
and at least not in my lifetime even if
they just stopped running forever so you
know which we were talking about this is
one of my favorite stats that doesn't
seem to get talked about is is if the
Yankees win it this year we're just a
guy you know I've kind of thinking the
Astros might get him I hear you'd bill
Berg you got this but this is big who
gets home game that could change it but
right if they win it this year then in
the last ten decades
you know they a century worth
the decades basically yeah they they
only once one decade they didn't win a
championship was the 80s they won at
least one World Series in nine out of
ten decades and you just think that they
went through everything all the change
an all-white league segregated League
intricate integration lowering the mound
free agency strikes other leagues
football taken over basketball they just
continued success right yeah you cannot
you can't mess with that if I'm not
mistaken if they don't make it it'll be
the first decade in which they don't
make it period to the world world so at
least in the 80s they made it they made
it in 81 in the strike shortened year
where they came out here and lost in
Lausanne
like that's a drought they haven't won
in since I was 21 my self it really is
amazing and especially the way they've
done it this time where they really they
didn't do the old-school Steinbrenner
way where they just were no well I and
everything it's it's all pretty much
their own guy the thing is is that they
did do it with the old Steinbrenner way
by trying to get you know that Staunton
for 300 million bucks we've Red Sox fans
were so up in arms that they thought you
know Derek Jeter gifted Stanton to the
Yankees in a trade and Stanton has
hardly done anything this year well my
favorite thing about George Steinbrenner
was nothing he liked better than a 37
year old future hall-of-famer with two
years left to sign him for five years
that was one of my favorite moments on
Seinfeld is when George's dad met the
Steinbrenner character played by Larry
David because George was was George dead
is that what happened and and and
Steinbrenner when George they thought it
was George Costanza was dead Oh
and so the George Steinbrenner went to
the Costanza's house to console him and
tell him the information and the only
thing his Danza calls Jerry he says - he
says to George Steinbrenner he goes what
the hell's your trade Jay Buhner for and
I fell off the couch when the line that
came back was Ken Phelps my baseball
people said Ken Phelps because that is
the Ken Phelps was the 37 year old great
guy that yeah
he was gonna be the next great Yankee
yeah but now they've totally reversed
course on that sort of thing but anyway
which I think they should have always
you know it's easy to say no but if you
look at their farm their farm team I
mean just the start I mean they're Mount
Rushmore is pretty much from their
system
yeah isn't really a lot of God and then
like maybe like a Reggie or something
like that but uh and you know when we
sold them Babe Ruth because we have that
Broadway show we had the density but
Gehrig mantle DiMaggio her right to
Jeter Mariano Rivera all these great
great players that they've had they've
all come from from their system so bill
burr here on the Rich Eisen show let's
talk about your special paper tiger
filmed it Royal Albert Hall how did that
come about in London ah played drums is
a hobby
and my favorite Led Zeppelin and big
jump on a fan and my favorite Led
Zeppelin concert footage is at Royal
Albert Hall and I just loved the way it
looked at the the film that they shot it
on and the shadows and everything I just
you know my whole stand-up career I've
been trying to work my way towards
shooting something like that and and I
don't know I just I went over there one
time and I was doing a obviously a much
smaller place I took a tour of it and I
was like this is amazing maybe I could
come here sometime and go see like a
symphony right or whatever and I just
kept going to England I kept selling
more and more tickets and then last year
we try to do a show there and it's sold
out and I went on stage I did a show and
went good but I could never get out of
my head that I was there yeah I just
kept thinking I'm standing with Robert
Plant stood and John Bonham's drums were
right there The Beatles - right yeah I
mean I mean a series history in that
place yeah but I've never really seen
the footage of that it's just that I
watched that Royal Albert Hall thing a
million times so I'd it's just the maple
kid and John Bonham right behind it so I
was kind of in my head and and we just
went out we had a good time and my
manager in the agent this kind of you
great place cuz you know I'm trying to
think I've done one in the North that
done one in the South East Coast West
Coast each one I try to make look a
little bit different I had one black and
white
and it'd just be like alright let's do
it and I was talking to Mike binder who
shot it and that's why it looks so great
and
we're both cigar smokers and it kind of
all came about that he wanted to smoke a
cigar with me in London that's how this
all came about that was the final nail
in the coffin that we were gonna do it
so I was really excited about it and
then leading up to it I was getting
nervous so it's just like what the hell
am i doing like London the different
country what if the jokes don't work
there critics are brutal mmm every time
I go there they just they trash me every
single time and oh yeah no critics
doesn't mess what they do you could have
the most perfect stand-up set wired it
wire nothing then they would still be
like the sickly bald looking onstage and
proceeded to have the greatest
performance like they're still gonna
find something so yeah that's how the
whole thing came about that's amazing
so yeah do you know people notice when
they watch it yeah the time that was
taken that Mike did the job and all of
his crew that they did like he just
knocked it out of the park it was this
special as far as visually what I had in
my head ever since I've wanted to do
them and and the pacing of the edits and
all that I think because I've seen so
many of comics that I'm fans of yes
where sometimes the way that their
specials are shot you know it didn't
showcase how good they were it actually
in a lot of ways knocked it down because
they they just edit edit and edit so for
us you know I'm watching him then I'm up
in the balcony and then I'm behind I'm
swooping in they shoot him like the
Bourne Identity which I don't understand
because like stand-up is like a small
intimate thing so like I don't know well
it's it's going gangbusters already did
you you sat down you told me something
and I you know sometimes I got a you
know my my ear piece in my ear so I
don't pick everything up because of you
know I've got getting ready for the
segment did you say you're in Star Wars
the Mandalorian the one that Jon Favreau
put together okay yeah I don't know if
I'm allowed to say I'm lab was in the
trailer you see the back of my bald head
for half a second I've never been a
sci-fi I like like Blade Runner there
was a movie that uh Sam Rockwell did
called moon okay like I like that sort
of dark creepy Stanley Kubrick
Space Odyssey I'd like that I was I was
never into the the Star Wars thing I
just by the time I saw it I was just too
old sure they had like a walks and stuff
and I wanted to see Fast Times at
Ridgemont High you know so I missed the
boat so I never got on it so and I've
religiously made fun of every one of
them that came out just teasing just cuz
people are excited he'll look at you I'm
a jerk you know so I see people get
excited about something I just make fun
of it and so I ran into John somewhere
I think hanging with Mike binder right
should start giving that guy Commission
okay I'm doing the Star Wars thing would
you want to do something else like I
can't always make fun of it he goes and
he was just going like I think that'd be
funny I think your fans will get a kick
out of the fact if you went into that
thing and and then I went in there and
they were shooting it like a spaghetti
western
and I was like immediately was like so
psyched to be a part of it that's
amazing you got to see the trailer yeah
I think it's the Star Wars I think I
think it's gonna take it - what am I
don't know anything about Star Wars but
I just the one that I saw once I saw the
stormtroopers heads on those sticks I
was like all right they're here I know
that's already been out I mean it comes
out in November yeah the trailer went
crazy
yeah are you in the new Breaking Bad
movie did you get that are you allowed
to pause okay you're not in that okay
that's another Netflix thing are you are
you showing up on better call solon any
point in time I know this is these are
honest answers or you can take no these
are honest answers I was I was supposed
to be on it uh-huh and unfortunately I
had somebody who was dying okay well if
I did it I was gonna I was gonna miss so
personally you could yeah I'd visit him
I had to say goodbye it sucked right it
the whole thing sucked because Vince
Gilligan is the reason why I have an
acting career as he put you in Breaking
Bad yeah yeah yeah and people always say
oh my god you were so great and Breaking
Bad I was going to say you would have
been great in Breaking Bad that's how
good they were now you have to do is say
what they wrote and stop on the piece of
tape right and they're gonna shoot it
and they're gonna make you look they're
gonna make you look good yeah well you
can still think I know how to act
because of Vince Gilligan well
Elda bill there's no doubt about that
before you go tis you have any advice on
being a new dad for Brockman over there
you got one you got a daughter you talk
about your your fatherhood we just saw a
clip in in a special oh you know what I
can do is just tell you that it's
awesome it's one of the few things that
lives up to the hype and do not listen
to 90% of other parents because for some
reason they they predict just like
misery they still do it like my
daughter's like two and a half I think
oh yeah what's that like and the second
you tell them you're enjoying it they
like oh wait she's two and a half and
one week oh then it's all gonna be you
know they just I always just say to Mike
you don't sound like you enjoy being a
dad just so I can watch him backtrack
the first few months stinks with the the
sleep thing but like I think Kevin
Nealon said one time he said I don't
care if you have to take out a second
mortgage get a night nurse you just got
to do it too just this whole idea now of
like that you're just gonna do it
yourself is a modern thing like back in
the day you just you didn't get a job
when you moved 3,000 miles away from
your log cabin it's just like you got
married and you live next door and then
you people helped you out you didn't
have to walk around like a zombie so if
you can afford it somebody's gonna trash
me for being like an elitist no as you
said take out a second mortgage yeah but
you're kind of also a useless appendage
as far as a dad where the baby does not
require you at all no but you've you
know you're you know what you are you
that you're that utility player they can
just stick you anyway you spike goin
right that's what you you just hand him
food needs to be done got it she needs a
diaper change just get that's alright I
just any time my wife elbowed me I just
sat up like a zombie went in there I
talked to her in a soothing voice you
know to try to get a stop crying change
the diaper handed her to my wife she
started nursing her went back to sleep
90 minutes later woke back up again yeah
I did that for like a week
and then before the night nurse came in
like the cavalry you're the Brock Holt
of The Situation's Kevin McHale's JT
force for any Laker fans watching my
favorite that was yeah I was about to
say you got some some Celtics right
there yeah I waited I
waiting to bust these out just Sal
Vulcano from Impractical Jokers hooked
me up with these so thank you fantastic
I think they're coming here aren't they
the in practice yes they're coming back
that's it from my hometown Stan Allen oh
is that right oh yeah I just shot a
movie out there there you go
then Staten Island I loved it no kiddin
yeah reminded me of where I grew up I
liked all the trees it was it was
quieter awesome where I grew up did a
show at the was it st. George st. George
yes yes that's right it's right there
where the where the ferry comes where
most people just stop and say they've
been to Staten Island get on the ferry
and go back home yeah I'd never been my
grandpa's had a al Lewis used to have a
comedy club there that's what I used to
go to grandpa's comedy it's not a loony
bin or shut down I think out there good
to see a bill burr all right everything
is trending up for you sir but you knew
that already
you're one of my favorites Thanks come
back anytime anytime at bill burr on
Twitter at Wilford burr on Instagram huh
and I didn't know I didn't know
Instagram was gonna be a thing I just
thought I was gonna die out like
Friendster I would have picked them more
named people could find me a little
easier well it's it's all working man
MGM National Harbor on October 5th and
DC the Asheville North Carolina the US
Cellular center you'll be there for it
that's right I'm going to I'm going to
that Clemson game I've got one big
college football game a year we're going
to Clemson and I was excited about
Clemson Florida State to that wide
receiver lined up on the in the wrong
way yeah first week jitters smarter wise
and then you'll be in Vegas in December
at the Cosmopolitan Casino Hotel and
Casino good to see you thank you you got
it that's bill burr check out his
Netflix special it's fantastic paper
tiger right now for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app